welcome everybody to what is
an exciting day in cardinals history we
are here to honor ted simmons
he will officially be inducted into the
national baseball hall of fame in
cooperstown
jake woodford will be charged with
retiring kepler
rooker and polanco in the first inning
his next offering is swung on missed
kepler strikes out and the first stop
goes to woodford for strikeout number 30
this season and 36 in the third innings
on the ground to arenado and a rare
miscue
by the gold glover as he backed up yeah
i don't i don't mind him backing up
because he's backing up to get the
better hop instead of the in between hop
he's going to get a bigger hop now
there's top spin on the second bounce
and that's what got him it came up
quicker
than he thought a lockhole switch hitter
batting left-handed
and the 2-2 pitch line drive into right
field down the line that's a fair ball
that's going to find the grass
the track and now the wall rooker to
third he is going to be held
it's a double for polanco as the throw
comes back in
so luis betting cleanup tonight second
and third one out no score and the 2-0
pitch
is sent in the year to left field down
the line over to his right o'neal with
the play
he'll catch it rooker tags he will head
home and no
throw in it's a sac fly for a rise
rooker scores
and the twins capitalize on the arenado
error and lead one-nothing first at bat
back
and snow bangs a line drive left center
field base it in the alley this ball is
going to find the wall
polanco scores miguel's going to second
base that's a two out double
it scores polanco twins laid two nothing
to ryan jeffers leading off ending
number two for minnesota split in the
two-game series the 3-2 pitch
strike three called just off the outside
corner and jeffers is telling nolen
played umpire carlos torres will take
that location too
and the 2-2 pitch a line drive into
right field that's a base hit
all right bailey over making some
history tonight two out
single into right and ober is on
twins dugout all smiles that ball is in
tony diaz's hands at third and now we'll
flip that
inside the twins dugout
and the one-two pitch is strike three
called on the outside corner that time
o'neill knew it
over comes back with heat up and away at
94 for his first strikeout and his 46th
this season over will go after yada year
molina in a 2-2 pitch for yada year
molina
yachty drills it up the middle of base
hit even with polanco playing
almost behind the bag the ball was hit
so hard polanco
put the glove out there and missed it by
maybe a foot
so one on one out red-hot harrison bader
and the one-two pitch swing and a miss
he struck him out in a high-fast ball
good location good target there from
jeffers set up in
and said let's get the fastball up with
his glove did just that
and over hit his spot too so now it's
tommy edmonds autumn two twins by two
and the pitch a swing and a miss strike
three high fastball
so that fastball is playing well tonight
early as ober strikes out
three and the cardinals do not score
after two twins two
st louis nothing rooker polanco arrives
due
up top three to you because that's going
to cost me some owners some more money
lying in the right center field that's a
base hit man rooker's got a great swing
shot that one to right center field he's
out for the second time money because
hey we got a 50-50 chance to get in the
playoffs lined to left field that's a
base hit snuck that one by
de young it's short so polanco pokes it
the other way
a two-hit knight danny now five for
seven in this series
what a stretch he is having offensively
that's his fourth straight multi-hit
game
nobody out twins lead 2-nothing in st
louis and the 0-1 pitch lined to right
field that's the base hit
ricker is going to round third and score
this one's cut off by carlson on the
track polanco is going to stop at third
base the twins have their third double
tonight that's a run scoring two base
hit for a rise
three nothing twins still two on wins
three cardinals nothing one in three on
nobody out larnick hit the ball well his
first time up but lined out
nobody out and the pitch is swinging a
fly ball into right center field in the
ballpark
bader over to his left he'll call and
catch it come in and throw in towards
the plate it's going to be offline
polacco scores and the runners hold
a rise at seconds to know at first a
one-two count to the twins catcher
and the one-two pitch of fly ball into
right center field and deep vader going
back still going he's gonna turn look up
that's gone
jeffers a three-run shot to right center
field the twins with a
big inning and now leads seven to
nothing in the third
ninth home run for jeffers
on a hanging off speed pitch and he goes
to the right of dead center field
and the twins with a five run third so
far now leads
seven nothing they play arnado the pull
and up the middle
on the infield straight away in the
outfield deep in the outfield
he leans back and waits on another one
here she comes and there's a line drive
base hit into left field in the left
center
it's cut off by the center fielder
that's kepler so nolan arenado with a
leadoff single there you go
and he hit one back through the middle
over 100 miles an hour for a base hit in
the second
here's another pitch on the way yadi
turns on a pitcher this is going to go
down to the left field corner and that's
going to go
to the wall arnotto will go into third
yachty thought about second and now he's
going to have to scramble to get back to
first and he is safe
aronado scrambles to get back to third
he's safe yadier molina with
a couple of hits tonight has tied albert
pujols
for fourth on the cardinal career list
harrison bader he's the hot bat for the
cardinals in july
bader did the right thing another pitch
on the way he turns on the pitch face
hit down the left field line
one run will score yachty will move to
second base the cardinals on the board
with their first run tonight
harrison bader continues to swing
another hot bat
as he drives in another run 7-1
minnesota
there's a ground ball right back up the
middle it's a base hit look out
mcgill with a two-hit knight that was a
rocket 117 miles an hour off the bat
here's the line drive base hit right
field good piece of hitting right there
by
anderton simmons one for three likes
hitting in
st louis locks on july 5th there's a
ground ball base hit austin deal he's a
hit machine
throw to the plate and it's gonna be cut
off throwback to second not in time
twins had one now lead eight to one so
two outs
and now kinsner and the one-o pitch weak
round ball right side this is polanco to
his left he picks and throws him out
and the twins win the game eight to one
this weekend series now even at a game
of peace rubber game at 1
15 tomorrow between pineda and
wainwright
the twins have a big night